le long des quais de Bordeaux un homme
nous entraîne discrètement dans les
ruelles de la ville
il veut nous faire découvrir un mais
exceptionnel que l'on ne trouve plus que
rarement dans les restaurants du centre
ça va et vous ça avance ça avance pierre
est un bon vivant et il sait où trouver
ce qu'il cherche à Bordeaux seuls les
initiés aujourd'hui le privilège de
déguster de la civelle
à Bordeaux aujourd'hui au moins et si
les gendarmes sont dans le secteur
on mangera pas de pibal
puis c'est interdit
Bibal civelle deux noms pour un même
petit poisson qui rend fou nous sommes
en avril trouver de la civelle fraîche à
cette époque c'est normalement
impossible car sa pêche est réglementée
et très surveillée
dans le Vieux Bordeaux une petite rue
piétonne à l'écart des grandes avenues
pierre retrouve son vieux compli
Jean-Paul et Fabien restaurateur pour un
déjeuner d'experts et de gastronomes
dans les cuisines Monique la femme de
Jean-Paul est déjà au fourneau
blanche
il y en a pour une petite fortune
à la vente ça dépend si elles étaient à
, vous comptez
ça fait 800 euros
la civen n'est pas la carte de ce
restaurant c'est un déjeuner privé
on peut pas mettre ça au menu il faut on
prévient les gens les gens réservent
mais on fait on fait quatre ou cinq
journées puis balles dans la nuit pas au
courant mais là ça va oreille ça va vite
et cette conversation vous pouvez les
reprendre alors chaude
pas question de gâcher le cérémonial et
les civelles ou Bibal ça se mange très
chaud mais un délice a presque interdit
aujourd'hui qui rappelle de bons
souvenirs à ses amateurs ça me rappelle
mon enfance
la civelle ou pibale c'est étonnant
petit poisson translucide est en fait
l’alvin de l'anguille
[Musique]
dans la région de Bordeaux comme partout
sur le littoral du Sud-Ouest il y a 15
ans lors de notre premier reportage la
civelle se pêchait par tonne la civelle
se vendait partout sur le marché local
mais surtout elle était exportée vers
l'Asie un marché légal très lucratif
à 400 euros le kilo c'était l'or blanc
de la Gironde et on bichonné le client
asiatique nos clients
la qualité de du poisson ils vont
jusqu'à regarder au microscope la queue
du poisson potentiel est abîmé
les têtes de dans les oui voir si on en
prend pas de micro-organisme parasite
il nous épluchez Steven quasiment une
par une d'ailleurs c'est vendu à la
pièce là-bas et bon il les regarde
vraiment de très très près
c'est bien vivant ça serait bien c'est
bien plus lucide
ça on peut l'envoyer sans risque
les yeux fermés rien à craindre
mais en 2007 coup de théâtre Bruxelles
sonne le glas de cette Man en classant
l'anguille espèce menacées trop péché
partout en Europe le petit poisson
disparaît peu à peu il faut sauver la
civelle est interdite les prix
dégringolent et le commerce de la
civelle est sinistré ils étaient mille
pêcheurs il y a 15 ans ils ne sont plus
que 400
ils ne sont plus que 400 euros
la chaque bouée que vous voyez là chaque
bouée c'est un bateau de pêche
aujourd'hui vous pouvez regarder il y a
plus personne ils sont combien sont 4 5
il y a plus personne on peut plus
survivre c'est fini
moi mon bateau est vendu j'arrête
elle a tombé de la nuit dans l'estuaire
de la Loire à la mairesse se prépare il
est pêcheur de chivelle depuis plus de
30 ans il sait que c'est sa dernière
saison pour lui comme pour les autres
fini la liberté cette année il a le
droit à 100 kg de prise rien de plus
le pêcheur aussi le plus nombreux là
je pense mais un quota viable pour tout
le monde on est des clochers
il y en a beaucoup qui vont arrêter là
parce que ils vont pas pouvoir joindre
les deux bouts c'est pas possible tous
ceux qui ont des crédits vont arrêter là
la saison de pêche est courte et les
sorties sont réglementées cette nuit
dans l'estuaire de la Loire les pêcheurs
ont droit à un quota de 10 kg pas un
gramme de plus
si les 10 kilos la pêche en 10 minutes
bon on arrête
le poisson apparemment est de retour
cette nuit là la mairesse atteindra son
quota en moins de deux heures
ça commence ça commence
une scientifique avec calculer que les
civils devaient disparaître dans les
années 2010
tout le monde s'est planté parce que
personne ne pensait que ça allait
revenir dans des quantités comme ça on
retrouve des niveaux qu'on a qu'on avait
dans les années 70 ça veut dire quoi
pour retrouver de telles quantités de
civelles il faut retourner 40 ans en
arrière
pour Alain mairesse les pêcheurs sont
aujourd'hui victimes de mesures qui ne
correspondent plus à la réalité de la
ressource de la civelle et ses
quotidiennement qu'ils ont subissent les
effets avant de repartir il faut la
peser au grand près
à question de transporter plus que le
quota autorisé et enfin il y a de la
paperasse à faire car avec les
restrictions de pêche les contrôles se
sont multipliés ces dernières années
normalement ça y est soit embarquer à
tout moment là si je remplis pas le
papier je démarre les gardes ils sont
planqués ils arrivent de faire donc je
remplis de papier avant de démarrer le
moteur il faut mieux
si les pêcheurs professionnels comme à
la mairesse sont régulièrement contrôlés
c'est aussi parce que la pêche illégale
c'est particulièrement bien organisé ces
dernières années
une petite route départementale dans le
Médoc près de Bordeaux Lionel Taillebois
et gare de pêche depuis 20 ans il dirige
la brigade régionale de l'ONEMA l'Office
national de l'eau et des milieux
aquatiques la voici au grand complet et
armée jusqu'aux dents
les braconniers ont été repérés ils sont
bien organisés très difficiles à
interpeller l'intervention ne pourra
donc se faire qu'à la tombée de la nuit
ça c'est avantages et ses inconvénients
la nuit nous on peut approcher
discrètement mais bon quand les
braconniers s'en vont ils peuvent partir
tout aussi discrètes sans qu'on les voit
il y a 15 ans nous avions rencontré
Lionel taibois et sa brigade la civelle
suscitait déjà toutes les convoitises
pas beaucoup
il venait de repérer des braconniers là
en plein action au bord du fleuve salut
les cartes de pêche
après avoir saisi le matériel de pêche
de ce braconnier récidiviste les garde
trouveront juste à côté plusieurs tamis
non réglementaires cachés dans les
buissons
la motivation c'est financier c'est pour
ramasser un peu d'argent
allez deux ou trois si belle il gagne il
peut gagner donc entre
2500 francs et puis
3000 4000 4000 francs soit 600 euros le
kilo pour ce drôle de petits poissons
c'était en 1999
15 ans après la civelle se vend moins
cher 100 euros le kilo quand même mais
elle fait toujours courir gare de pêche
et braconnier la lutte s'est même durci
ce soir près d'une écluse la brigade de
Lionel taillobois vient de rattraper un
braconnier alors qu'il était en fuite
vous veniez pour vous faites quoi de la
civelle pour vous capturer
pour les manger apparemment cela nous
convainc pas le brigadier surtout avec
un tamis de cette taille
et mais on connaît déjà monsieur
déjà dressé un procès-verbal il y a deux
ans il était chez il était carrément
chez un maraur en train de porter des
civils pour les vendre et ce soir il
nous dit que c'est pour les manger quoi
si j'étais chez
le braconnier ni même qu'il était en
train de pêcher il faut dire qu'en 15
ans les choses ont bien changé le
braconnage de civelles aujourd'hui c'est
possible d'une peine de prison
pourquoi
à l'anguille d'une façon générale est
passé dans le régime du délit
la commercialisation est beaucoup plus
encadrée néanmoins est-ce qu'on en a
fait assez pour sauver l'espèce ça ça je
sais pas
est-ce qu'on en a fait pour améliorer la
situation oui voilà après est-ce que ce
sera suffisant ça je saurais pas le dire
alors que sait-on aujourd'hui sur ce
petit poisson menacé en fait l'anguille
reste un des plus grands mystères du
monde marin apparemment le bébé anguille
est très au large de la Floride près du
Triangle des Bermudes dans la mer des
Sargasses au début ce n'est qu'une larve
leptocéphale 3 mm à peine puis c'est la
migration minuscule elle met un an à
traverser l'Atlantique et arrive sous
forme de civelles dans nos estuaires
elle grandit alors en eau douce pendant
une dizaine d'années et prend sa taille
adulte de Bel anguilles avant de
retraverser l'Atlantique pour retourner
en mer des Sargasses l'endroit précis où
elle est née
à Dinard au Centre de recherche du
Muséum d'Histoire Naturelle
Eric fenten consacre 100% de son
activité à cet étrange petite bête ce
professeur en biologie marine vient de
faire une découverte importante il a
trouvé comment calculer l'âge anguille
adulte lorsqu'elle reprend la mer 5 6 7
8 je retourne sur un bord où je vois
mieux 9 ce serait une anguille qui
aurait au moins 9 ans
si les désormais facile de déterminer
l'âge exact de l'animal difficile en
revanche d'expliquer le comportement de
l'anguille quand elle rentre en mer des
Sargasses le lieu où elle est supposée
naître et se reproduire
les scientifiques ont employé les grands
moyens
une cinquantaine d'anguilles ont été
équipées de balises Argos puis relâchez
en pleine mer première information
données par ces balises la vitesse
phénoménale à laquelle nage ce migrateur
jusqu'à 45 km/h et surtout la profondeur
extrême à laquelle il plonge
le jour elle descendent jusqu'à 500
mètres 1000 mètres et le record c'est
1600 mètres de profondeur là où l'eau
n'a une température qui n'est que de 4
degrés et ensuite pendant la nuit elle
remonte à proximité de la surface ça
veut dire que c'est un mystère de plus
malheureusement parce que pourquoi
font-elle ça pour percer ce mystère
étant d’autres les chercheurs ont même
carrément envoyé des navires
laboratoires sur le lieu supposé de
ponte et là petit miracle
pour la première fois ils ont trouvé il
y a quelques jours des œufs dans le
Guille européenne c'est la première fois
qu'on en trouve donc ça veut dire
qu'elles naissent bien emmerder
le travail d'un scientifique c'est aussi
de sortir de son laboratoire pour aller
vérifier dans les cours d'eau l'état de
la ressource que l'on dit au bord de
l'extinction aujourd'hui
Eric fontaine se rend sur l'un des
barrages de sa région pour compter les
civelles bloquées au pied de l'obstacle
ça c'est pas des civelles c'est déjà des
anguilles qui ont un an ou deux ans
donc la bonne prise ou pas là
c'est un petit bout de temps qu'on avait
pas vu ça autant de capture
en 48 heures
Fabien me disait tout à l'heure que
qu'on a déjà dans la dans cette saison
ci capturé plus d'anguillette que dans
toute l'année dernière
rien qu'aujourd'hui on en a 1000 donc
c'est une année qui s'annonce
exceptionnelle
d'habitude un barrage une écluse c'est
un obstacle pour l'anguille qui remonte
les cours d'eau mais ici le biologiste
marin a trouvé la solution
les anguilles qui remontent là-dedans
vont tomber dans la benne ensuite la
benne va remonter jusque là haut va
s'ouvrir dans l'entonnoir et les
anguilles vont être automatiquement
libérés en amont ça a été mis au point
ici d'ailleurs quand on a expliqué qu'on
avait mis au point un ascenseur anguille
sur ce tout petit cours d'eau on avait
mis les visites de japonais de Canadiens
de d'anglais enfin il y a plein de gens
qui sont venus voir
en 2007 l'anguille était en voie
d'extinction serait-elle aujourd'hui de
retour comme le prétendent les pêcheurs
il faudra sans doute plusieurs années
d'observation pour le savoir
mais les scientifiques vont pouvoir
cette fois compter sur des alliés
inattendus retour dans nos estuaires
nous sommes près de La Rochelle chez
Jérôme Guru tchaga l'un des plus gros
marayeurs français d'habitude le marior
c'est celui qui achète le poisson au
pêcheur pour le revendre sur le marché
salut Thomas
tu vas bien
vend une partie de ces civelles pour la
consommation principalement dans les
pays scandinaves mais le reste et c'est
ça la grande nouveauté sert à repeupler
les rivières c'est la règle depuis le
plan de gestion mis en place par
Bruxelles en 2007 pour sauvegarder
l'espèce
c'est là c'est une très très bonne
qualité elle est prête à partir
sans souci pour un déversement
qui devrait se faire demain
mais avant de les déverser dans les
cours d'eau certaines de ces civelles
vont être marquées tout simplement pour
les suivre à la trace tout au long de
leur croissance une nouvelle tentative
pour percer le mystère de ce poisson on
peut les retrouver au bout de trois ans
de 4 ans dans une pêcherie dans cinq ans
et on sait qu'elles ont été identifiées
tel jour qu'elles ont été déversées à
tel endroit on sait tout dès le départ
sur ces allevins là pour le marquage de
la civelle c'est simple il suffit de les
colorer on en sélectionne d'abord
quelques-unes on les endort on les pèse
on leur fait un petit bilan de santé et
on les trempe ensuite pendant trois
heures dans ce liquide rouge un produit
qui malgré les apparences et tout ce
qu'il y a de plus naturel
là on va
on s'est un produit qui est rouge
et qui rentre on va dire à l'intérieur
de la civelle et qui va se fixer sur sur
l'autolyte donc c'est ce qui va
permettre de les reconnaître dans les
suivis futurs voilà pourquoi depuis le
plan de gestion de Bruxelles les
entrepôts des marayeurs ressemblent
désormais à des laboratoires d'analyses
après l'éprouvante séance de marquage
lessive ont bien mérité un petit repos
avant le grand départ
il est 4h du matin Jérôme Guru tchaga et
son équipe prépare une expédition 350 kg
pour un repeuplement en Bretagne dernier
opération minutieuse pour le mariage les
transporter vivantes
donc c'est une caisse spéciale poisson
vivante que nous utilisions autrefois
pour pour expédier vers l'Asie qui
aujourd'hui sert pour faire des
déversements sur tout le sol européen à
partir de ce moment le compte à rebours
commence 35 heures c'est la durée de vie
garantie par l'emballage un petit coup
d'oxygène un pack d'eau glacée et elles
sont prêtes pour l'expédition demain
toutes ces civelles nageront librement
dans les rivières bretonnes un petit pas
pour la sauvegarde de l'espèce
après les directives de Bruxelles le
métier des maréeurs a considérablement
changé
il y a 15 ans lorsque nous avions
rencontré Bernard Bambie son entreprise
de mariage était florissante chaque
semaine des camions bourrés à craquer de
civelles transit et ici avant que la
marchandise ne reparte pour l'Asie
principale client à l'époque la société
faisait 8 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires par an et Philippe Mabit par
les chaque jour au téléphone avec des
intermédiaires chinois
je pense qu'on doit pouvoir faire une
expédition autour du 6 autour de 300 3
400 kg bah nous on travaille on fait 10
ans 80 dès maintenant 99% de notre
trafic de civelle avec la Chine
15 ans après la réglementation de
Bruxelles est passée par là une pêche
limitée à 35 tonnes et surtout
l'interdiction d'exporter la marchandise
hors d'Europe pour Bernard Mabille c'est
le début de la fin il n'était jamais
revenu ici depuis la fermeture de son
entreprise c'était il y a deux ans
je sais pas
c'est dans un état
tu nous fais quoi
c'est bien malheureux
comme ça j'ai jamais eu des véhicules en
si mauvais état
camion laissé à l'abandon et à
l'intérieur du hangar il n'y a plus rien
[Musique]
voilà les anciennes installations
à les vestiges parce que il y a juste
les emplacements des bassins ici on
avait trois grands bacs
[Musique]
voilà le même décor mais sans les
meubles
il reste que le
les murs et la moquette et aussi
accroché au mur cette vieille carte de
Chine toutes les civelles françaises ou
presque atterrissaient ici pour être
transformé en anguille et Hong Kong
toute la zone où il y a les
les élevages pour ce chef d'entreprise
la décision de Bruxelles a été trop
rapide et trop radicale le marché est
devenu de plus en plus difficile de plus
en plus dur on pourrait donner des
quotas de façon à ce que les pêcheurs
vivent un peu mieux de de leur travail
parce que actuellement il y a pas de
prix étant donné qu'il y a pas
d'exportation sur la Chine
alors pourquoi le Parlement européen
a-t-il pris une décision si tranchée
selon les scientifiques la population de
civelles avait diminué de 90% en 25 ans
à peine
sur pêche mais aussi une multiplication
des barrages pollution des cours d'eau
il fallait réagir et c'est cette femme
qui au Parlement européen de Bruxelles a
mené le combat le stock d'anguille est
dans une situation très critique
elle s'appelle Isabella Lovine elle est
députée européenne tendance écologiste
engagée en 2007 pour protéger l'espèce
elle a fait adopter un plan de gestion
qui a entraîné de nombreuses mesures
quota de pêche aménagement des berges
repeuplement et surtout interdiction
d'exporter la civelle
mais pour la députée ici en discussion
avec des experts de la Commission pêche
ce plan de gestion doit être encore
renforcé et tous les moyens sont bons
pour sauver l'anguille
si les stocks ne se reconstituent pas
alors oui il faudra limiter encore plus
la pêche
limiter la pêche ou carrément
l'interdire
si vous me posez la question alors oui
je suis pour l'interdiction mais avant
de faire adopter cette mesure radicale
au Parlement la députée doit récolter de
nouvelles informations auprès des
scientifiques
Eric fontaine notre spécialiste mondial
de l'anguille et justement à Bruxelles
pour rencontrer la députée et lui faire
part de ses derniers travaux
ce que je ressens de mon expérience sur
le terrain c'est que les anguilles
commencent à revenir dans les rivières
même si le stock est toujours très bas
le problème c'est que les pêcheurs ont
l'impression d'être les seuls à faire
des sacrifices
moi je pense qu'au stade où on en est
rien de justifie que l'on puisse pêcher
de civelles qui sont en danger pour
ensuite les vendre plusieurs milliers
d'euros le kilo en Asie tout ça juste
pour faire du profit
pensez aux générations futures qui
n'auront pas la chance à cause de ça de
connaître cet animal fantastique
[Musique]
le déclin de l'espèce si on montre du
doigt les pêcheurs j'ai peur qu'on
oublie tous les autres
accepté que vous puissiez continuer à
défendre la tuerie d'un animal juste
pour récolter des données scientifiques
je suis pas d'accord
été écouté du tout c'est quelqu'un qui
qui a une opinion très arrêtée sur sur
le fait qu'à partir du moment une espèce
s'est qualifiée comme en danger c'est le
cas de l'anguille et bien il faut
absolument interdire toute source de
mortalité à commencer par la par la
pêche moi je pense que pour l'anguille
c'est plus compliqué que ça alors que
faire interdire la pêche durcir le
règlement ou au contraire l'assouplir
une chose est sûre la demande asiatique
est toujours aussi forte et le prix au
kilo encore très élevé jusqu'à 1000
euros
il y a 15 ans à l'aéroport de Roissy des
tonnes de civelles françaises partaient
à destination du marché chinois en toute
légalités par semaine
[Musique]
il y a à l'époque nous avions fait avec
elle le voyage qui nous avait amené dans
la plus grande ferme d'élevage d'anguy
au monde près de Shanghai 50% des
civelles françaises arrivées dans ses
bassins
chaque année la ferme produisait 30000
tonnes d'anguilles pour un chiffre
d'affaires de 1 milliard de dollars ici
grâce à un élevage très intensif et une
nourriture particulièrement enrichie ont
transformé en à peine 6 mois 1 kg de
civelles en une tonne d'anguille
l'interdiction de les exporter en 2009 a
forcément favorisé le commerce illicite
c'est désormais chez les douaniers qu'on
retrouve nos petites civelles entre les
animaux empaillés les défenses d'ivoire
et la drogue
et voilà le
procès-verbal concerne la saisie d'un
énorme colis pour la Chine
voici les images de cette saisie 50
caisses de civelles françaises vivantes
comme celle-ci qui ont échappé à tous
les contrôles un butin estimé à 250 000
euros 250 kg Devel donc là très
clairement quand vous arrivez à des
quantités comme ça vous savez que vous
êtes sur un réseau organisé un réseau
structuré qui organise des filières
clandestine d'importation d'exportation
de ce type de marchandises qui se
revendent souvent très cher en Asie quoi
et cette filière démarre la nuit dans
les estuaires avec des braconniers de
plus en plus organisés
les civils de contrebande transitent
ensuite chez certains Maria qui en
quelque sorte les blanchisses
discrètement avant d'organiser
l'expédition en Chine une opération
extrêmement risquée ce commerce est
presque autant surveillé que le trafic
de drogue les sommes en jeu sont
considérables
certains arrivent pourtant à exporter en
Chine en toute légalité au Maroc nous
retrouvons Jérôme bouroux de chaga
souvenez-vous c'est ce Mario qui faisait
le marquage des civelles et les rejeter
ensuite dans les rivières bretonnes pour
le repeuplement
au Maroc il fait du business là où
l'interdiction de sévi-pins il y a 8 ans
il crée la première ferme dans X
[Musique]
cette réussite Jérôme la doit en partie
à Asma sa femme marocaine sans elle les
choses ont été bien plus compliquées
mais bien considéré parce qu'on est des
sols alors l'activité à ces drôlement
développé car jamais le Maroc n'a vendu
350 tonnes d'anguilles choses
qu'aujourd'hui nous le Maroc produit et
voici ce qu'a créé ce couple
franco-marocain 80 bassins sur une
installation de 3000 mètres carrés ici
on élève l'anguille de la civelle à
l'anguillette jusqu'à sa taille adulte
mais d'où viennent ces civelles
dans leur migration depuis la mer des
Sargasses elle peut aussi des estuaires
marocains comme à Kénitra dans le nord
du pays mais ici pas de quota pas
d'interdiction d'exporter et une pêche
artisanale qui fait vivre un millier de
famille et du poisson il y en a
de cette rivière elle est très riche de
l'Angola c'est depuis qu'il est petit il
exerce ce métier de pêcheur tant que ça
les jeunes et les les habitants de ces
villages autour de cette rivière leur
pêche et entièrement acheté par la
société de Jérôme gourouchaga et chez
lui tout est informatisé il y a un
moment 120 tonnes de poissons en stock
pas loin de 4 millions de pièces cela
représente un stock qui a une valeur
très très importante pour ne pas rester
sans aucune sécurité toutes les sécurisé
de A à Z tout est contrôlé de A à Z
système contrôle aussi l'alimentation
qui se déclenche automatiquement les
anguilles sont nourris toutes les deux
heures au menu c'est granulés composés
de farine de poisson de céréales et de
vitamines seules les civettes
bénéficient d'un traitement de faveur
des œufs de cabillaud servis à la main
il faut de 12 à 14 mois pour que les
civils deviennent des anguilles adultes
et puis enfin partir pour l'Asie
ce matin en espérant 1500 kg pour la
Corée pour un chiffre d'affaires de
20000 euros
mon cher que la plus belle au kilo mais
tout aussi rentable lorsqu'on fait de
l'élevage intensif
on retrouve le système d'emballage et de
conservation mise au point en France
polystyrène un peu d'eau place et
oxygène
il est 5h du matin le chargement peut
partir mais moins de 35 heures ses
envies seront déversées vivantes dans
les Didier coréens
dans les escales dans les avions un
petit peu partout c'est ce qu'on a comme
contrat avec la compagnie pour que ça
arrive tout vivant à destination il y a
15 ans les civelles qui arrivaient de la
mer des Sargasses partaient vivantes de
France pour l'Asie aujourd'hui c'est du
Maroc et transformé en anguille qu'elles
prennent la même route
entre temps cette étonnant petit poisson
aura fait courir gendarme et braconniers
pêcheur et gastronome il aura été classé
dans la catégorie des espèces menacées
fait l'objet de quota d'interdiction
susciter de nombreux débats
scientifiques et politiques acharnés
tout cela sans révéler ces mystères et
c'est loin d'être fini